بالعوده الى التوقع المخابرات الوطنيه
الامريكيه استمرار تباطؤ وتيره القتال في
اوكرانيا لعده اشهر تصريح ياتي على اعتاب
اشتداد قسوه الشتاء لكن ما الصعوبه هنا مع
اقتراب التراجع الحادي درجات الحراره
ستؤدي الوحول والثلوج والبرد الى تعقيد
مهمه كل من القوات الاوكرانيه والجيش
الروسي في الاشهر المقبله فالجنود سيشعرون
بالبرد وسيكون من الصعب صيانه اسلحتهم
والياتهم لتبقى في حاله جيده وسيغطي الثلج
على الغام وهو ما يجعل اكتشافها صعبا هذا
لا يمنع امكانيه القتال لكنه بالتاكيد يحد
منهم ويتوقع خبراء ان يتركز القتال حول
الكره بسبب الملاج التي تؤمنها القوات
التي تسيطر عليها تؤمن من المعدات التي
يقدمها الحلفاء للقوات الاوكرانيه من
ملابس دافئه ومعدات خاصه بالبرد الشديد
لاوكرانيا تفوقا على روسيا التي تواجه
مشاكل لوجسيه منذ بدايه الحربي اصلا وعدت
كندا بتقديم 500,000 قطعه من الملابس
الشتويه بما في ذلك ستوترات وسراويل
واحذيه وقفازات بينما تقوم لتوانيا بتجهيز
25,000 جنديا اوكرانيين بالكامل لفصل
الشتاء